what's up guys Mary here with gamespot's
the mix at e3 2015 i'm here with tonya
short hey Johnny hi Mary thanks for
being here with Kitfox games and you're
here to show us moon hunters Yeah right
this is a four-person coop right yes
Alyssa will be playing this together so
let's go ahead and get into it right now
sure so you can play alone but we have
four different character classes which
is great if you want to play with your
friends and try it all the different
abilities each of the classes plays
pretty differently and we're gonna skip
the story for this demo because you
don't have time for that we don't have
time for stories no nothing this game
flip we gotta gotta fight some monsters
so this is set in ancient Assyria okay
in Mesopotamia and you're trying to
solve the mystery of the missing so you
adventure out you're an agent bureau for
mythology and you're you're building
your mythology as you adventure through
the ancient world by making choices
really so you're trying to survive
obviously there's dangerous beasts out
in the wilderness but there's also
decisions you have to make together to
decide how you're going to build your
reputation okay so here we hear a
strange sad chanting it seems to be
echoing from the deep in the well a pack
of belongings have been left outside of
it so would we steal it or do not I'm
cheating or stealing it one person chose
not to so they're gonna they're going to
have a nicer reputation than the rest of
us we all take it together wait yeah in
the end the pack was taken so will
suffer for that but whoever voted to be
the nice guy gets a little bit of the
start of a reputation okay so we know in
May row decisions as a group you can
actually have your own personality
exactly what shoes to be the good person
in a pack of jerks absolutely yeah okay
yeah cool that looks to be your role on
this adventure somebody's got to be the
good guy yeah and then in between each
adventures you camp you on your hero's
journey you decide how to spend the
evening in between adventure so I'm
going to stargaze a little bit here it
builds up your stats tells you a little
bit about your personal this is me it's
all I'm terrible at hunting you yeah
well you might get better throughout the
adventure you know you start out a
little bit
great and hunting it turns out okay I'm
foolish yeah and I'm stargazing and
there's a chance it's random chance I
can't tell you whether or not is going
to happen now sources so random but um
somebody might have a personal choice to
make out here you go ok so the Druids
cooking is a hazlit decision to make Oh
interesting so we don't get to vote on
that one because that's their their
private adventurer basically add more
water to the super all right we got a
somewhat sleepy which well it's pretty
fascinating that you're giving us all
the ability to oh they didn't weakness
you know this is a randomly generated
map ok so now we vote on where we're
gonna go next we're in the tutorial so
we're just going to go to the village
going to kapar it's been decided and we
have enough opals it looks like we can
upgrade our abilities so here each class
can choose between two different
abilities I'm gonna choose kind of
trading dark blast so I'll just take
that well this is great out of here so
it looks like you can pull enemies
towards you or have a dash a dash that
does damage is awesome alright so just
press B to cancel and we'll explore the
rest of the village ok so now you can
try out your village the age-old
tradition of stealing everyone's stuff
but breaking all of their surroundings
that is beloved to them oh man some of
the animations and this are really
really tremendous I absolutely love the
look of the game art the art direction
is just fantastic thank you yeah I hopes
in is watching right now yeah amazing
thank you it's a yeah so we're moving on
with the plot it's a first moon piece
time and then we'll head out on our
second adventure sweet thanks for this
so everybody's got a vote are you ready
for the bridgeland feast everybody we're
already alright it's been decided I
don't know if you play a lot of co-op
game yeah I mean I've always been a big
fan love gauntlet and this has a huge
hammerwatch vibe I just enjoyed the
campaign immensely i love the old
gauntlet look and feel to it there's
something really wonderful to me about
being able to work together but then
still having that element of selfishness
to it looks like you really captured
that well here it looks like we have the
ability to be your own person while we
still work as its let's choose the
forest going to let's check out the
forest is we already seen the desert
yeah we wanted to have everybody you
know everybody has their their own goals
in addition to the group role so
everybody wants to find the missing
Rooney but what kind of a hero your
cunning hero or a prideful hero really
depends on how you approach the
different problems that you come across
in the world i'm not a huge believer in
quests as a designer I much prefer to
give players the ability to do what they
want and then give them a place to do it
so like if we had explored around and
talked to more villagers we would have
found more hints of different things we
can look out for plot threads that we
could follow up on and this level is
procedurally generated so I actually
have no idea what we're going to find oh
it's fantastic so it has the ability to
be different every time you get to have
a new adventure even though and that's
really good too especially with these
games because I'm to do is there
permadeath or what happens when you die
no you brought back to the village so
you lose some time there's basically a
time limit before the Sun cult kind of
takes over and starts burning things
down if you've wasted a little bit of
your time if you die but you're allowed
to keep going we don't want to ruin the
party I think it's important that you
can give your controller to a friend a
cousin a little brother and not worry
too much but more forgiving than average
yes that's definitely not a not a rogue
like I am I
what is that oh we call that Ursa Major
this is a bear thing down yeah yeah he's
wild that can you ever have any
specialty drops or any kind of like
elite animals that maybe give you
something else besides just a standard
heart oh yeah so there's a boss fight
later in this love I don't think we're
going to get to it we're almost out of
time but uh we we could fight the Sun
cult itself in this level somewhere and
we're building in a familiar system so
the party kind of gets say a magical
creature that follows them and helps
them out different ways depending on the
creature we have to find them in the
wild if you're convinced them that you
know it's worthwhile for their time to
join the party but that's a right now we
have another seven months the games
coming out in January as moon hunters is
coming to pc in january and then
playstation 4 in the spring okay so
they're in anything console meanest
eventually yep yep yep in here somewhere
in the distance yeah we're showing at
the PlayStation boo 33 right now my
first III it's pretty exciting oh yeah
III is always good it's totally
overwhelming it is a little bit it's
overloading on your like 100th time so
in your first probably just more crazy I
don't think it over ll ever get easier
no but yeah I mean really ash yeah we
all gotta get it some kind of dash the
druid turns into a dog or a wolf to
journey a little bit faster oh yes South
so cool I love our different skills oh
there's somebody somebody doing
something down here talk to her all
right we're here OE apples but they are
not for you yeah it is actually a
goddess and Norse mythology so we've
adopted her to fit into a more
Mesopotamian mythology because golden
apples are actually in ancient Greek as
well golden apples actually play into
multiple mythologies on the ancient
world what happens if the slit is
divided and it's two verses 20 then the
leader is a tiebreaker okay and the
leader is the one that people tend to
talk to more often
so like the village leader you might
have a seeker talk to him it's the
person with the highest charm and when
you can't if you rest you get more
charms you can kind of fight over who's
the leader if like you you might rule it
out for the leader we should add that
right now it's really just charm but
it'd be funny if you could sway people
by feeding them up that would be very
ancient world politics we have a little
clusters coming out of us we all get
healed if you run over the little
healing yeah oh because the druid
upgraded their mas ability to be like
well let's see yeah it looks like
strewed later on as we level up you know
the guys will get harder but we'll have
all these additional skills and points
which will really help us later on in
the journey yeah exactly that's
fantastic I absolutely love games like
this I'm really excited to see more and
just kind of check this out when it
actually comes out so thank you so much
Tonya thank you all right that was moon
hunters be sure and check that out and
be sure to stay tuned to gamespot com
for all your III 2015 needs